I'm gonna start before any adventures
for the magazine before I was out in
Antarctica before any of this happened
I'm gonna start by telling you how cool
I was as a kid because honestly I was
pretty cool I was the first hipster ever
sideways trucker hat I was kickin ash
Kosh B'gosh popped collar the whole deal
but really the point of this picture is
to show you that from a very young age I
was in campgrounds and my brother and I
were in campgrounds and we were always
raised to be in campgrounds as my
parents would have it they wanted us to
go out from the tiniest stage and go out
and experience the world and push our
boundaries and try to understand what
the world was around us and that was
very important in my family so they
started a skiing when we were two
climbing when we were five in the whole
point was to sort of define our own
borders this is me in the Wind River
Range close to where I live now in
Bozeman Montana
at about I guess I'm 11 12 years old you
know this is when questioning boundaries
started to take a different turn I was a
smart kid I went to high school two
years early and you know exploring
boundaries took on a completely
different texture at that point and what
I mean by that is I started exploring
social boundaries rather than physical
ones and when you're 12 years old in
high school and you're hanging out with
18 year old kids you don't have that six
years of experience to prepare you for
that and so honestly by the time I was
14 years old I was completely dropped
out of high school my parents sent me to
rehab I ran away three times and on the
third time as they say the third time is
the charm my parents gave up and it's
not that they they wanted to give up or
or I blame them for that but they said
quite honestly Cory we're scared of you
we we don't know what to do and if you
can't abide by our rules
the
you can't live at home so I was 14 and
homeless I look back on the privilege of
education and I shudder to think what I
was thinking but that was the decision I
made but that time period led me to
observe the world from a very curious
place when I am on the streets which was
rare because oftentimes my friends
helped me and I wasn't actually sleeping
on the streets too much but sometimes I
was and when I would see people picking
out of garbage cans it took on a
different tone to me when I myself would
have to look for food it took on a
different tone and what I mean by that
is I started to see this as closer to
our natural state that is a forager
foraging and everybody in this room is
actually much further removed than our
evolved trajectory then we then we like
to think that forager is far closer to
the way we evolved and and it was that
story that time seeing people struggle
that actually got me excited about
telling bigger stories and thank God for
my parents because they did start me
climbing so young that it had a
gravitational or I guess an
anti-gravitational pole back to it
climbing was a thing that got me out of
this because I came back I was driven to
do something and oddly enough visually
and in just in the very nature of it its
allegorical to human struggle it's it's
perfect for telling the story of what
humans are capable of and how much we
can overcome and not only that visually
it's just stunning and you can grab
people and you can capture their
imagination so my early career was all
about this I would go out and I would
take pictures with really crappy cameras
and I would try to side to sell them to
to companies and with that money I would
go on other trips and I'd save it and
I'd save more and I go on bigger trips
and I'd sell to different companies and
so that's how my whole early career
worked
and for a while it was very sustaining
and I loved it because you know I was I
could say I was a professional
photographer and people would really
respect me and I was really proud of
myself you know it's kind of proving
people wrong at this point I was proving
everybody that said I wasn't gonna
amount to anything wrong I was saying no
I'm gonna amount to something and I
think a lot of my early career was
dedicated to that a lot of it was
dedicated to making single images and I
call these single stories right so a
single story is is an image that you
provide to a company that inspires you
know some sort of inspiration that
really inspires people to buy raincoats
so I am a glorified raincoat salesman
which is fine or at least it was it was
okay with me early on but I started to
see this divergence between these single
image stories that I was hired to tell
and the larger narrative that I was
really engaged in the things that I
really wanted to talk about which was
not the heroic moment it was the
absolute offset it was the antihero
moment it was a thousand-yard stare it
was it was my version of conflict
photography in the outdoor space I
wanted to talk about what it liked what
it's like to hurt what it feels like and
naturally as you travel you know for
those of us who have had the great
privilege of traveling the more you
travel the more engaged you become you
become engaged with culture and you
start to grow a certain sense of
compassion or at least I did this is a
picture that I took a very very long
time ago but I remember it distinctly
because all of a sudden after looking at
this image back in what ass coming out
of the hills and Peru I remember looking
at this and thinking climbing is kind of
dumb
and it's true because it's a very
self-indulgent act and I realize I
needed climbing a because it sustained
me and B because it took me to these
places but the most important thing was
a thing that I had missed to that point
I was so engaged in my own struggle and
telling that story that I was missing
everybody around me so culture became a
very focal point in my early development
but again I wasn't I wasn't a
photographer of any note at this point
nobody was going to hire me to go tell a
cultural story I was always going to be
hired to go tell the story of mountains
and that's okay this is a picture of
Mount Everest on the left the little one
in the middle is load C in 2010 Conrad
Anker one of our other explorers asked
if I would go here and install
time-lapse cameras on the Khumbu glacier
to monitor deflation and it was for Jim
Bay logs movie chasing ice because we
wanted to look at the pack the impacts
of climate change on the glaciers in the
khumba region coincidentally you know
Conrad could kind of sense this I mean
Conrad's been a climber for a long time
and he could just see me looking up kind
of like I mean the time-lapse cameras
are cool but that's really good cool
like you know I want to go there and so
we actually finagled we called down to
Katmandu and I got a permit to climb
load C there was no way I was going to
get a permit to climb Everest at this
point it was too late but they they they
got me a permit to climb load C and it
was unlikely that I was going to do it
there was no way because most people
take about eight weeks and they go up
and down and up and down to get
acclimatized I had been there for three
weeks I hadn't been higher than base
camp and you know I had six days to tell
if the summer window so people were like
well good luck have fun you know go up
don't die
that's a common theme in my life have
fun don't die but I ended up climbing it
I ended up climbing it in six days so a
total of you know three and a half weeks
from my house to the top of the fourth
highest mountain in the world and that
got noticed it got noticed by a guy
named Simone a mortal now Simone Amato
is an Italian climber he's known for
hard first winter ascent and he called
me after this climb and he said in this
awesome voice I'm gonna do it again you
guys ready
he thought ladies he cause ladies he
said Cory do you want to go - ahem -
what did I meet Dennis and I said I
don't understand what you're saying but
I would love to go with you because
you're my hero where are we going - uh
from - I'm like okay that sounds great
where's that and he goes it's in
Pakistan and for those of you don't know
there's there's 14 8,000 meter peaks in
the world so 14 Peaks that are above
what roughly 26,000 feet and nine of
them are in Tibet Nepal and five of them
are in Pakistan and the nine into that
Nepal have all been climbed or had at
this point all been climbed in winter
but none of the Pakistani 8,000 meter
Peaks had ever been climbed in winter
because they're about 600 miles north
the weather is much more severe and
people would you know a lot of people at
this point I think 16 expeditions over
26 years had had tried and failed but
here's the thing I jumped I left before
thinking I didn't even know any of that
likewise I didn't know that if I did
this I would be the first American to
climb any 8,000 meter peak in winter but
of course I said yes and and all of a
sudden I was here on the on the literal
physical border of India and Pakistan so
that's something to pay attention to I
remember taking this photo
mostly because I
not happening I knew the Sun was gonna
crest and I knew you know the we're on
her summit push here and I ran ahead in
crampons that's really hard
it doesn't look cool you're like you
know I ran and because I ran I was just
so out of breath that I immediately
vomited and then I grit my can I get my
camera out I take my mittens off it's -
I think it's actually - 50 and I like
pull it up and I realize I can't take it
I like it's frozen I can't turn it off
shutter priority whoo so I can't change
the shutter speed I can't do anything
and it's at a 50th of a second which for
those of you who don't know that's very
slow especially when you're just vomited
and you're like trying to do this and I
took this picture and and that was that
was that I knew that moment was special
because I also knew in that moment that
we were very likely going to summit but
the summit there was just the beginning
like I said I didn't know I'd be the
first American I didn't know any of that
and to be fair had I known I don't think
it would have been good for me I was
climbing out of pure joy and I loved it
as we got to the summit a storm hit and
on the way down we were hit by a massive
avalanche six days out on to our summit
bid one day the last day to base camp we
were hit by an avalanche and I sent this
picture to my mom when we got back and I
said mom I just we made it we're back
safe and she goes ooh
it's a lovely portrait is that Dennis
and I said that's me mom she goes ooh
like ooh that's gross and I'm like yeah
because I look like I'm like 90 you know
it is gross my face is all swollen did
you guys know that more people have died
this year from taking selfies than like
shark attacks and lightning combined now
it's bad news don't do it but but do
keep taking selfies because apparently
you can get them on the cover of
National
geographic that's a thing but honestly
to get serious for a second that that
moment as much as the Avalanche was a
defining moment in my career and this
image became something it became much
more than I had ever anticipated it
represents something much deeper and I
look at it now I look at the gesture I
look at the facial expression and what I
see is somebody who's struggling to deal
with a traumatic event a very very
traumatic event what happens to the
brain is when it thinks it's going to
die it prepares it quite literally
prepares for death and so when people
say you know my life flash before my
eyes that's a very real thing it's not
the way you think of it it's not like
all these beautiful visions and things
sometimes you're like Cheerios parking
tickets you know it's all of it like
compiled and but I see this now and what
I see is is a person who is alive
realizing they're alive after their
brain has prepared for death and what
that manifests as in Psychological terms
is PTSD that's where it goes from there
the experience is locked in your brain
you your sympathetic nervous system
kicks in and you are continually
experiencing that moment from that point
on
so it's spinning out and essentially
that's just a corrosive method for your
brain and what you do is you try to find
anything to calm that spinning down and
swear all addiction stems from so I
didn't know it at the time but jeetu had
given me the first American to do
something an 8000 meter peak in winter
and PTSD it's the gift that keeps on
giving but we'll get into that I went
home and I got married I got married to
a wonderful woman we had a wonderful
group of friends we had incredibly
supportive families we live an alternate
we lived an alternate lifestyle that you
know some parents would be a little
alarmed by like okay you're gonna go
climb mountains and you're gonna go
climb rocks and we had very supportive
family
but the problem was that even right
after my marriage I started to feel
disassociated and I started to feel
withdrawal and I started to feel
confusion and darkness and I didn't know
what it was I felt like there was a
weight pushing down on me like a literal
weight I'd wake up in the morning and my
brain was just going and it was like
this very loud silence and it reminded
me of a quote that I read a quote from a
book it says they carried all that they
could bear and then some including a
silent awe for the terrible power of the
things that they carried that's by Tim
O'Brien from the book the things they
carry jeetu didn't just leave me with
PTSD it gave me something else it gave
me an opportunity to provide a
storytelling example to National
Geographic
there was a soldier's a Pakistani
military camp at base camp and because
we were there in the winter they were
very welcoming they opened up their
doors to us they were sort of intrigued
by us who are these three crazy guys
climbing in winter because in the
summertime you can't go here it's just
off-limits because there's too many
people up on the glacier and and you
know these guys are 18 to 24 years old I
was so alarmed by what I had seen in
western media and what was actually
happening there so I took on the task of
trying to communicate their story in
very very brief terms because I wanted
to come back and have something to show
to say deke warrior who had asked she's
my photo editor here who had asked hey
can you show me some storytelling
examples it was a very unique
opportunity extremely unique and to look
back at these and see what I was trying
to do I can understand it and I think
you know some of them are okay but but
oddly enough I just want to tell how we
got here these guys would come over to
our camp and they kind of peek in and
you know it's like looking like you know
they were six-year-olds and then they'd
have like kind of nervously walk in and
we'd have tea with them and then finally
the reason it all worked out the reason
we became friends is because they asked
hey Cory I know you guys have internet
could I check my facebook so now I have
like a ton of friends named Farouk
Mohamed and I'm on the TSA watchlist
which is awesome I can't get on a plane
save my life
but you know it's a real lesson in in in
creating intimacy and learning through
nonverbal communication and trying to
take pictures that told deeper more
meaningful stories and and really using
that which is different to show that
which makes us all the same I love this
photograph it's like not technically
perfect what self-respecting
photographer leaves a shadow in the
bottom like it's like hardly in focus
but the guy has a purple tracksuit like
that is dope that is awesome and who
drives their clothes in minus 40 why
would you do that but the thing is it's
just like I'm a guy out drying my
clothes sure I'm in the Pakistani
military on the highest battlefield in
the world but guess what it's relatable
and that's what brings us together
that's the power of photography it
brings us together and brings us closer
this is hard live living up here this is
very intimate space and to be invited in
and to be shown that level of friendship
was a true gift and it made me connect
with these guys in a way a very real way
where I started feeling much more for
their struggle and their struggle is one
that is is very very real Bertrand
Russell has a wonderful quote says war
does not determine who is right only who
is left and you know I found this this
foot of a Pakistani soldier frozen in
the ice on the glacier and it occurred
to me that this is somebody's son and
probably somebody's brother and maybe
somebody's uncle this you know these
wars are ugly and they leave scars and
our actions is he
have consequences they all do but this
led me to my first assignment for
National Geographic they said yeah you
can take a couple pictures we'll try out
might not go so well but we'll give you
a shot it was to an area called moose
song it's on the northern border of
Nepal
just south of Tibet and you know it was
pivotal for Tibetan freedom fighters at
the end of the Cultural Revolution but
before that for thousands of years
before that it was a space of absolute
beauty and mystery we were using
climbing to access these caves and and
what I what I love about that is it back
to you know one of the previous
photographs
it's the hook Adventure is the hook to
get people involved in science and then
we can talk about culture and human
migration so you when you're telling
stories you want to bring these elements
together that's sort of what I found
works best for me an effective
storytelling always brings you in it
brings you very very close it takes you
into the caves it gives you the smells
and the textures it shows you that dry
dry that sort of sand everywhere but
it's interesting when I look at these
now too I feel like there's a parallel
with what was happening in my life I
felt like I was standing at the opening
of a cave looking in well not wanting to
go in but just sort of being sucked in
and not being able to see and feeling
completely the sense of vertigo I didn't
know what was happening and much like
mat is doing here I was picking up
random pieces and trying to fit them
together and figure them out but nothing
seemed to work
in this image mat is actually finding a
piece of pizza
they chose ancient script a lot of times
they looked like this pick it up blow
the dust off you know it was tax records
or things like that
sometimes it would look like this and
that is an illuminated folio that
predates Buddhism this is bun so this is
what this is the animistic tradition of
the Tibetan Plateau
before the spread of the spreading of
Buddhism it gives it a deeper
understanding of how the culture there
evolved
you know it's really about taking images
that take tiny little pieces of the
puzzle and then put them all together
that's what a visual narrative is and
some of them have to take bigger leaps
than other but its its construction from
the ground up and you have to open
yourself up to seeing things in a very
different way after a very long time we
finally found what we were looking for
which was human remains this is rescue
archeology these these these caves are
actually literally exfoliating off the
side of the mountain so we'd go in and
we'd collect samples that we could what
we were really looking for here were
teeth now if you think of this in in a
in a way basically human remains are
like finding the corner and the edge
pieces of a jigsaw puzzle right once you
have that you start to piece things
together the reason teeth are important
is because there's in in your tooth
enamel there's something called
strontium it's SR 38 on the periodic
table and what that has in it is is a
geo thumbprint essentially it tells you
where you were born so if you can find
somebody's remains and you get there
there's strontium index and they were
born someplace different than where they
died and you do that with everybody in
the burial crypt well all of a sudden
you're painting a very real picture
about human migration and trade and this
is the story of our human family this is
why this matters we're connecting the
pieces and what's so important about
that and I think it's more important now
than ever now this is ancient history
but ancient history matters because it's
only through understanding our past and
I mean there's so much especially this
week only through understanding our past
can we hope to navigate our future so we
have to pay attention to this stuff
when things you know when we look back
and we look at the events that happen
how can we predict the future and
hopefully how can we alter it to go down
a better better road because you know
honestly we all look up at the sky and
we think oh the world's so big and it's
it's infinite you know what it's not you
know the sky might be infinite but the
war
old is very very very finite it's
extremely finite in an extremely fragile
[Music]